ANTONY PASSEMARD: And welcome
everyone for the CCAI session.
This is the state of
the union for CCAI.
Really happy to have you.
I'm Antony Passemard.
I lead our conversational
AI product at Google Cloud,
and really excited
about all the things
we're going to talk about.
It's an exciting
time because we are
in the middle of a revolution.
It's a revolution
of conversational AI
and conversational technology.
CEOs are already
adopting the technology.
About 31% of CEOs have deployed
conversational AI platform.
It's 50% growth year over year.
This is a massive adoption
of this technology that has
matured in the last few years.
We're seeing that
customers by 2023
will prefer a speech interface
to initiate cell service.
70% of them said so.
This is a rise from 40% in
2019, so pretty big change.
On that same day 2023, about 40%
of contact center interactions
will be fully automated by AI.
This is a very big change,
too, because right now it's
only about 25%.
It was 25% a couple
of years ago.
Also a big change
that is happening.
Customers and consumers
of your product
are getting really familiar
with the conversational AI
technology.
This is, obviously, because
they have Google Homes.
They use search on
their Android phone.
90% of them are familiar
with those technologies,
and 72% have used
voice assistant.
That means that
consumers are getting
trained on those technology.
They are getting
more comfortable
using their voice to do
something to ask of Google
or ask of any of
their application
on a day to day basis.
There was a trend in the
past where we thought
chat would replace voice.
It's not happening.
Voice is growing
very fast, and CCAI
is there to answer that call.
So what is CCAI?
CCAI is really three
products inside Google.
We have Dialogflow for
automating interactions
and self-service, we
have Agent Assist that
is used to help an agent
in a contact center
deliver a stellar
experience, and we
have a little newborn,
CCAI Insights,
which is in alpha right now.
Really helps you
understand all that
is happening in your contact
center, the code writers,
et cetera.
So before we dive
into those products,
let's look at a little video
to see what an experience could
be with Contact Center AI.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[RINGTONE]
- Hi, Prisha.
Thanks for calling our bank.
How can I help?
- Hi, I'd like to pay my bill.
- Great.
Can you please
verify your address?
- 15 State Street.
Oh, and how much is it?
- Virtual agent provides
immediate conversational
support with customers
directing the flow.
- You owe $150.
Do you want to pay with
the account ending in 1337?
- Yes, please.
- Done.
I've sent an email confirmation.
Is there anything else?
- Virtual agents can take
care of basic fulfillment
on the spot.
- Yes, actually, there's a
$35 charge I don't recognize.
- From last week?
It looks like it's
an overdraft fee.
- Oh.
That's not fair.
I didn't know.
- OK, let me transfer you
to a specialist to help.
- More complex
cases are seamlessly
handed off to a human agent.
- Hi, Prisha, I'm Elliot.
I see you're concerned
about the overdraft fee?
- Yeah.
I didn't know I
would get charged.
- OK.
I can waive the fee
this time, but would you
like overdraft protection
so it doesn't happen again?
- Agent Assist listens
in, giving real time step
by step guidance.
- Yes, please.
- OK, I've set it up.
Is there anything else?
- No, this was great.
Thanks a lot.
- Lastly, Insights gives
you real time visibility
into key call drivers
and sentiment.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So
what you've seen here
is an example experience
of using first Dialogflow
for that self-service
experience,
getting context, helping the
customer as much as possible,
doing back end calls, getting
the information to them
in order to solve a problem.
But when the call needs to
be escalated to an agent,
Dialogflow transitions
very smoothly to the agent,
gives all the
conversation context,
anything that happened
so the customer does not
have to repeat again, something
very frustrating for customer.
Repeat information, [INAUDIBLE]
themself to whatever.
This is all taken care of by the
transition between Dialogflow
and Agent Assist.
The conversation's
picked up right away.
The agent is assisted
in real time.
No need for the agent
to search on their own.
They'll get
information proactively
thanks to Agent Assist,
and then all the insights
in the back end are helpful for
coach, QAs, product managers,
any person in relation
to the activities that
are going on in the contact
center will use that.
This experience is
possible because we have
a fully integrated product.
It's an end to end solution
for a contact center
starting with advanced
conversational AI
technology at the core, the text
to speech, the speech to text,
and the NLU who are powering
the virtual agent for voice
and chat as well as the human
agent with real time prompts
Agent Assist, and even
Dialogflow bots that
can help the human agent.
All of that data being created,
all of those interactions,
are being fed into
Insights to have
a holistic view of all channels
across the contact center
and really understand
what is going on.
When we're looking at the value
created by Contact Center AI,
we see two main links.
The first one is
the human agent.
How do we help a human agent
with Contact Center AI?
Well, by bringing
those suggestions
to the human agent
at the right time
with context
understanding of what's
going on in the conversation,
the human agent will be faster,
will have more
accurate responses,
will provide better information.
Better data will be
relevant and look very good,
like a powerful agent.
Look like they know
what they're doing.
And that's very important
because the human agent
will feel empowered.
They'll feel like a super agent.
And that's a better
experience for the agent,
which means a better experience
for your customers eventually.
It will also reduce churn.
Churn is a big problem
in a contact center,
as you probably know.
Between six months to 12 months
for a full contact center
refresh of agents,
that's not good.
Training costs are hard.
The skill level of
agents is not perfect.
With Agent Assist, we can
really help solve that problem
and make sure that human agents
can do a good job right away,
feel good about their
job, and provide
the best experience
for your consumer
or the people calling
in your contact center.
The second links are the
customers, the consumers,
the constituents sometimes.
They get self-service
channel 24/7
through conversational
chat bots and agents.
This is great.
They can really have their
problem answered whenever
they're available for it.
They have shorter
call time with agents.
The agent knows everything
after transitioning from an IVR
to the agent.
The agent has all
the information.
They get the information faster.
The calls are shorter.
The first call resolution
rate increases,
and the brand loyalty as a
consequence and the trust
to your brand and
to your institution,
your organization
are greatly improved.
So those two core
sets of value--
human agent and
customer-- are really
what CCAI helps to
deliver, and we really
understand the
challenges that are
common across contact center.
You're seeing ramping
operational costs.
You're seeing long
average handle time.
You're not having enough agent.
Especially in this time of a
pandemic where the demand is
exploding contact
center cannot follow.
They have to turn to technology.
They're facing high
turnover, costly training,
lack of visibility
using sampling to know
what's going on in
the contact center.
With Contact Center
Insights we can solve that.
There's seasonality
issues they need to solve.
Really, Contact
Center AI is there
to solve all those problems
across your contact center
challenges.
A great example that
happened actually
at the beginning of the pandemic
with the state of Illinois.
Unfortunately, many
people have lost their job
during this pandemic.
This is very bad.
And they had to file
claims for unemployment.
And in the state of
Illinois, they've
seen 3.2 million inquiries
in the first two weeks.
This is massive.
This is something they've
never seen before.
How could they handle this?
They quickly deployed
Contact Center AI
with an agent to help them
answer unemployment claims.
They've handled more than
2.6 million voice and chat
interaction through
the Virtual Agent,
and have been able to
answer 99.9% of clean claims
in a timely manner.
The results is astounding.
Very quickly set
up using partners
like Quantifphi, and
Cisco, and Presidio,
they've been able to
set that up quickly
and serve their
constituent in the state.
That was a great
success story for them,
for us in a very difficult time.
So let's look at the
key CCAI offerings.
Let's focus first on Dialogflow.
We mentioned Dialogflow
with a self-service tool
to build bots and make sure
that customers can interact.
Dialogflow has been in
market for a long time.
It's been about
three, four years now.
The transition was taken
more than two years ago
to focus on enterprise use cases
and contact center use cases.
Thanks to that,
it's been deployed
in customers like Discovery, a
financial services firm; Marks
and Spencer in retail;
Verizon for telco;
we have digital
native companies;
other financial services,
fortune 10 retailer
for their employees; USPS.
If you're calling
for your passport,
that's powered by Dialogflow.
The list goes on and on.
The adoption of Dialogflow
has been incredible.
And especially in the last
year and a half, two years,
we've seen a massive growth
in usage of Dialogflow.
You can see it in numbers.
1.4 million developers have
signed up on the platform.
This is a massive
increase from last year.
This is because we support
up to 22 languages,
and there's more coming.
We have one-click
integration with partners
to get a phone number, and
a Dialogflow bot behind it.
Partners like AVaya, Genesis.
SignalWire, Box Implant,
or [INAUDIBLE] notes.
Dialogflow can scale to massive
amount of agents and intents,
20,000 intents per agent.
That allows basically,
if you simplify,
somebody to call in and
ask about those 20,000
things for a single bot.
This is an order of magnitude
bigger than most out there.
Dialogflow is HIPAA
and PCI compliant,
and easily used in health
care and financial services,
as you've seen.
And really, we're seeing that
enterprise adoption, enterprise
growth, Dialogflow becoming
the standard for building bots
at enterprise scale.
And today, we're really excited
to announce Dialogflow CX.
Dialogflow CX is the next
evolution of Dialogflow.
This is all the
learnings we've had
in the last few years about
what makes Dialogflow great,
put it in place to serve
the enterprise market.
And the complexity and the
scale of enterprise customers.
You're seeing here a
visual flow builder.
This is one of the big
asks that customers have.
How do we create complex
flows with Dialogflow?
Dialogflow CX enables that.
You're going to have a drag
and drop visual flow builder
with graphical transition
that you can just
set up and make sure that
you can build bots very,
very quickly.
It has native support for all
the things that Dialogflow has.
The 20,010 per agent [INAUDIBLE]
agent, the native support
for sentiment analysis at
each term, the custom voice
support, and I'll
give you an example
of custom voice with text to
speech that's really exciting.
We have CI city pipeline
in Dialogflow CX, which
allows you to do
A/B testing of bots
and be able to have
two different versions
of the same intent and be
able to test their performance
before you deploy.
We have created an advanced
NLU for Dialogflow CX, which
is based on a massive
transformer report model
and outperforms the
previous NLU model we had,
which was already a
leader in its market.
We have better analytics
and debugging tool,
which are important
in large deployments
because many people are
working on those bots.
It's not just one
person, and you
need to have those debugging
tools and analytics tools.
And very importantly,
we heard of customers
asking for simpler pricing.
The pricing on Dialogflow
CX is based on sessions.
There's two prices, a voice
session and a chat session,
and that's it.
There's no consumption, no
time, no how many queries
you're doing.
You have a voice session,
there's one price.
You have a chat session,
there's another price.
Makes it very easy to
know how much you're
going to spend
with Dialogflow CX,
and we're really,
really exciting.
So Dialogflow CX is
going to be beta--
is beta today, sorry, and
we'll go GA in the next couple
months, or few months.
Let's focus now on Agent Assist.
Agent Assist is all about
empowering human agents,
making sure that human
agents are the most effective
in their job.
As we know, human agents
are oftentimes new.
Maybe don't know
the new products.
Maybe are not comfortable
with some of the information
that the customers
are asking them.
So what it does, it does a live
transcription of all calls.
And I'm saying all calls
in your contact center.
Any call coming
through is transcribed.
This is very new to a
lot of contact center.
Most contact center-- actually,
many do call recording,
but do they ever look at
those call recordings?
Do they know what's
in their call?
Not so much.
With a live
transcription, you now
have transcription
of every single call
coming in your contact center.
And those calls are used
and this transcription
are used to do article
suggestion and FAQ
suggestion in real time.
It will listen to
the conversation,
give you information,
documents, FAQs,
whatever the agent needs to
answer a question will come in.
We can also provide guidance
through a Dialogflow bot.
If throughout a conversation
an intent mapping to a bot
is detected, saying,
I want to book a trip,
a bot can probably handle that.
You need a destination, a date,
how many people, et cetera,
et cetera.
The bot can guide
the human agent
through all those
questions and make
sure the human agent
is not missing any.
This is really helping the
agent be more efficient.
Less time spent on the phone.
More focused because you don't
have to put people on hold,
and search, and ask around
for different answers.
And really makes the
new agent more aware
of the brand taxonomy, and
whatever terms the company is
using, and types of
answers the company
wants the agent to provide
to their customers.
So lot of benefits.
Agent Assist was
launched last year
as a voice channel
transcribing all calls,
and we've had a lot of customer
asking for that same experience
on chat.
So I'm announcing today
a second announcement,
Agent Assist for Chat.
Agent Assist for Chat does
all the same thing as voice.
Will do document suggestion
if it gets [INAUDIBLE],,
but because you're
on a chat channel
you can do a little bit more.
So you can do smart
replies and smart compose.
Smart replies are proposing
several possible replies
that the agent can
click, modify, and send
right away to the customer.
This is very
helpful in a context
where agents have two or
three chats in parallel,
and they have to switch
context all the time.
Because of the smart reply,
they can go to a window,
quickly see what kind of replies
they can send, and send them.
Shorter time again.
More accurate responses again.
Smart compose is
what you've been
used to seeing in Gmail,
for example, or your G Docs.
If you're typing, it
types ahead, saving time,
reducing the number of typos,
having more accurate responses.
We integrated the
same technology
Gmail uses in the chat window.
Again, efficiency for agents,
better user experience,
less training required, and
lower onboarding effort.
A great launch.
Very excited.
This is really interesting.
Let's look at the third pillar,
CCAI Insights, in alpha right
now.
Insights is about
visualizing and understanding
what is going on in context in
your contact center operations.
From pure data,
just how many calls,
and your lengths of
calls, but really drilling
in the voice conversation.
That's important
because, as I said,
you probably do record
your conversation.
But do you know
what's being said
without doing just Sampling?
Sampling will make you
miss a lot of things.
A lot of intents are not
detected about subjects,
a lot of topics are
not found, especially
if they are not that common.
With Insights, you
can have topic modeler
and really understand all
the drivers of your calls,
but go to a conversation
level and really
see what conversations
happen, what
are the sentiment
across conversation,
drill in a conversation,
see all the transcriptions,
hear the audio if you're
authorized to do so,
and really understand
what's going on.
You can do compliance check,
and QA managers in particular
love this product
because you can
search through the conversation
and find all the conversation
that were not good that they
can really focus instead
of doing sampling and trying
to find out which ones were not
good.
It's very hard to do
on [INAUDIBLE] only.
With insights, it's trivial.
We're really excited
about CCAI Insights.
Still in alpha right
now, but very quickly
will go to into beta.
It does conversational
analytics, [INAUDIBLE]
session reviews, as I said.
It's a complete
solution that integrates
with the rest of the
Google Cloud Platform.
For example, a native
export to BigQuery.
Very important.
You have CRM data, or ERP
data, or other database
that you want to
ingest into BigQuery
and map it to your customer
interactions in your contact
center.
Insights allows you to do that.
Very easy to tie
all that information
from your customer
interaction into the rest
of the interaction
with your customer,
either your marketing
campaign, your sales
campaign, or whatever
interactions you have.
This allows you to really
leverage the power of Google
and the power of
the platform itself.
And finally, that
search and query
allows you to find information
within those conversations
very quickly and really
focus your effort
to improve your
customer experience.
So if we dive a
little bit deeper
into each of the underlying
technology for those services,
the goal of Google AI
is really to enable
conversations that are as
close to human as possible.
We're not claiming that we're
going to replace humans.
That's not the case.
But we want to be close
enough, and actually, we
advise our customers--
because you'll hear some
of the custom voice thing--
we're going to
advise our customer
to let people know
that they're talking
to a bot and not a human agent.
That trust is very
important, and we
want to make sure that
consumers and customers are not
deceived by the experience
we're providing with Google AI.
Google AI benefits from deep
research in our Google AI team,
but DeepMind as well.
But benefits also from a
lot of the Google search
research that is happening.
Lots of very, very
smart AI people
working on search, voice
search, working on the Google
Assistant, working
on the Google Home,
even building specialized
hardware for AI-- our TPU
that you may hear
in other sessions,
our TPU allows us to iterate on
the models and the performance
of those models and do
inference very, very fast.
Enabling, for
example, the speech
to text in real time
in streaming mode.
So with those
technologies underneath,
we can create AI that
understand what's going on,
that can talk and interact
with the customers.
If you think about speech
to text in particular,
a core underlying technology
for conversational AI.
Massive dictionary.
120 languages
supported in the API.
You can bias the
model at each turn.
And actually that
biasing is used
in Dialogflow which, just
by clicking one checkbox,
can bias the model in each
turn of the conversation
inside Dialogflow.
It's called [INAUDIBLE]
speech biasing.
Dialogflow knows the context.
Speech to text can be biased
based on that context,
and automatically
that biasing's done,
which makes the intent
detection accuracy much higher
than if you don't
use that biasing.
And that's currently
unique to Google.
We can detect several languages,
formatting, do real time.
I'll spend a little bit of
time on the language support.
Many companies will
claim language support.
Many companies will claim that
their model works best here
and there.
You have to be careful about
models in speech to text.
You will need
different models based
on the quality of the audio,
based on who's on the line,
based on the length, et cetera.
Let's do a speech to text
for a long conversation,
a video, subtitle.
It's a very different audio
quality really from your noise
background than an agent
in a contact center.
If you've been in
a contact center,
you know it's a very
noisy environment.
A little headset.
People are talking
left and right.
It's hard, and most people
will call from a phone, eight
kilohertz quality.
Two people are
talking on the line.
Very difficult.
If you apply the
same speech model
from transcribing
a video conference
in a context of contact center,
that's not going to work.
We have five languages
optimized for telephony,
optimized for contact center.
Spanish, English-- English
US, and English UK--
Russian, and I think we have
another one I can't remember.
Australian or
something like that.
Those language supports are very
important because they really
make sure that the transcription
are done correctly,
that the documents suggestions
and then the insights we get
out of it are done correctly.
Very important to think about
the optimisation of the models
that you have and
what we can provide
based on what use cases.
The IVR model will be different
from the Agent Assist model,
and we provide all of those.
In speech to text, innovation
is happening almost
on a monthly basis.
Pretty impressive improvements.
But today, we're announcing
the third big move
in conversational AI,
speech to text on-prem.
Speech to text on-prem was
a big ask from customers,
especially in the financial
services and health care.
What they really want, that
processing of the raw voice
data done on premise
before it hits the cloud
for other types of processing.
For example, a DLP processing--
the data loss prevention.
Removing all the
PIs from the text.
Now you can deploy speech to
text on-prem using Anthos,
which is our platform
for their multi cloud
and hybrid platform.
You can deploy speech
to text on-prem
and have exactly the
same functionality you
would get under the cloud API.
The US English
support, multi-channel
with several people talking,
recognition, the diarization,
custom recognition
of specific words,
very important for health
care and financial services
as well, actually.
A lot of terms are specific
to those industries.
And the noise robustness
that is required
in particular in contact
center environment
when there's a lot of
background noise, et cetera.
So this is a super
exciting launch.
Managing the on-prem deployment
through an Anthos console
in the cloud.
So doing the on-prem the cloud
way with the modern deployment
capabilities, the
tracking, the analytics,
and all the good
things you get out
of Anthos now enabling
speech to text
to be available for you on-prem.
Very excited about this launch.
Now let's talk about the other
way around, when you have text
and you want to speak it out.
We have been leading
at Google text
to speech with several
generation of technologies.
The first one that's being
used right now quite a lot
is WaveNet.
WaveNet came from our research
arm at Google DeepMinds,
and it's a voice that
sounds fairly engaging.
Pretty close to a human voice.
Much less robotic than
the traditional voice.
You have 220 voices
to choose from--
female, male, different tones
and speed, and 92 of them
are WaveNet voices
across 32 languages.
It is actually very
easy to go test it out.
You go on
cloud.google.com/texttospeech.
You can put a little
text, choose your voice,
choose your language, and
you will hear it speak.
Very easy.
I actually have a little
bit of fun myself.
I put, for example, English
and I take the French--
I put some French
in there, and I play
with the little combination.
It's very interesting
to see what it does,
but it's pretty
impressive, actually.
So WaveNet has been
a great success.
The text to speech
API is very easy
to use through REST or GRPC.
You can insert pronunciation
hints, like pauses
and how to say certain numbers.
Obviously you're not going
to say a phone number the way
you say a dollar amount, or a
credit card number, or a date.
So all those you can put little
hints in the text for the text
to speech API to adapt
to what needs to be said.
One thing we're announcing
today, I talked about WaveNet
and how it works great.
We have now custom
speech, custom voice.
It's basically the
ability to train
a specific model for a customer
based on a human voice actor
and replicate that voice actor's
voice for text to speech.
I can already hear some of
you say, oh, that's scary.
Well, the technology
is pretty impressive,
and you'll hear about it.
But we require an ethics review
for any deployment and access
to this API.
We want to make
sure that customers
are using custom voice
in an ethical way
and are not abusing
the voice of an actor
to do things that
are not ethical.
So we are gating access to
this API through a review.
And when you hear the example,
I think you'll understand why.
So let's listen to
two simple audio.
One is a human actor
saying a sentence,
and the other one
is the model based
on that human actor saying a
sentence that this human actor
never say.
Let's listen to the
first one, the actor.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- According to Science
Direct, a flexed posture
is characterized by an
increased thoracic kyphosis.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Obviously I'm not a doctor,
and I have no idea
what she said.
But it's interesting to hear
her voice and her pitch.
So now let's listen to the
bot version of that voice.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Contact Center AI brings
the best of Google AI
to customer service.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
But you're saying,
I find it a little fast,
so we could slow it
down a little bit.
But the voice is clearly
distinct and clearly the same
as the actor.
So that technology is available
for any customer following
an ethics review.
I want to use custom voice
inside Dialogflow CX,
for example, for
the IVR experience,
or any kind of voice
experience they want.
One customer was very keen
on using custom voice.
That customer is Verizon.
Verizon has entered a digital
transformation of that contact
center experience using the
best of contact center AI
from Google and bringing to
market an impressive customer
experience throughout
all their channels.
We'll look at a video of
Shankar, as VP and CIO
of Verizon, talking to
Thomas Kurian our CEO,
about their expense,
why they chose CCAI,
and what has been their
success and experience so far.
So let's listen in.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Today I'm here with Shankar
Arumugavelu to talk about some
of the work we've been
partnering on with Verizon.
How did you select
our contact center AI?
- High fidelity synthetic voice.
That was an important factor.
The platform that can handle
our scale was critical.
In all of these areas we
saw Google CCAI excel.
- What does success
look like so far?
- Whether it is over a
voice call or a chat,
an absolute language
recognition finds the best way
to assist them in a consistent
manner across all channels.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANTONY PASSEMARD: We're
so excited to collaborate
with Verizon on this experience.
Verizon is really leading
the innovation in the space,
has a massive contact center
with a lot of complexity
and scale that we're able to
deliver successfully to them.
It's a testimony
of our technology.
of their innovation
and their trust in Google.
So I'm personally
super excited about it,
and the whole team
is going to be
using a lot of the technology
that I presented today.
The launch of Dialogflow
CX; with the [INAUDIBLE]
in Visual Builder;
the STT on-prem,
which can be used by financial
services or health care
institutions; the chat assist,
which has been in high demand
and being adopted very
rapidly; and the custom voice.
All those launches are making
the Google Contact Center AI
technology leading
in the market,
really getting traction, and
picking up the largest contact
center with the most complex use
cases, and the largest scale.
Very excited to be able to
help our customers solve
your contact center experience.
Something really new that
was not really available
a few years back.
And now I love to be
part of that journey,
and I hope you're
going to engage and do
that transformation yourself.
Thank you very much
for listening to me,
and I hope you enjoy
the rest of Google Next.